[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the government
is about to sign the death warrant for
manchester united
[Music]
hospitality is being punished for
something that
it's not hospitality's fault
[Music]
there's definitely a sense in the north
we feel like we're getting picked on now
i think it's a different version than
norfolk come out of this
[Music]
liverpool may have owned the 1960s but
30 years on
by the 1990s manchester's ecstasy fueled
dance scene in clubs like the hacienda
created a new
music mecca local band stone roses new
order the smiths
oasis and joy division ensured the
city's place
on the global map creating a music
tradition that has
endured and evolved until now
this is where people come to make music
see music and get um
just drowning music it's almost like uh
somebody turned
the pa off and it's gone to silence this
is the tense period now this is a bit
where we don't quite know what's going
to happen next
the venues are all shut it's stop start
stop starts
you can't put gigs on what do you do
with these spaces what to do with these
people
manchester's ian curtis sang that love
would tear us apart
now kovid is doing that to the music
scene
posters at the castle hotel pub are
relics of a buzz
that went quiet in march
izzy walsh used to perform packed rooms
and was getting noticed
internationally now her audience isn't
what it was
i think it is pretty unfair if they are
honest
we're still kind of like stuck in this
limbo of being like well when
are we allowed to go back to our jobs
under local restrictions since july the
31st manchester households haven't been
allowed to mix including inside pubs but
the city authorities are resisting
pressure to close them completely
at some point the cure is going to cost
more than the uh
the disease so to speak and i just feel
like we're teetering on that line at the
moment that if we if we
continue to push too much uh with these
restrictions and lockdowns and
and preventing people just getting back
to normal then
i mean i fear that my children's
grandchildren will probably still be
paying the debt off
pub goers are equally worried about
where this is going
social interaction human interaction
that is passing on this virus was
prematurely virus
but it's what we are it's what we are
it's the very essence of our being can
you not understand that
it's what we are if you if you if you
deny that it's totalitarian
along with mancunian brit pop the 90s
saw the growth of higher education
and manchester thrived with europe's
largest student population
a diverse gay scene merged and a
hospitality sector
that now employs 420 000 people
each restriction cuts a chunk out of it
and the coming winter's not helping
either manchester has this
thing that happens on a daily basis
called rain
and look at it now who's going to sit
there and especially when the
temperature drops
sasha lord the mayor's nighttime economy
advisor is preparing a legal challenge
if the government tries to impose tier 3
restrictions
if they want to close our pubs and our
bars down
without any scientific evidence then
we've got queen's council
ready but not everyone agrees
from the mayor's nighttime economy
advisor i'm now off to meet andy
burnham's former press officer who
is now shielding sally wheatman was
recently diagnosed with cancer
and believes the city should help
protect the vulnerable
i was at christie yesterday i was
surrounded by hundreds of people
like me who are literally fighting for
their lives and we're in a position
where our immune system is going to be
seriously compromised obviously we want
to be as safe as we can possibly be
and if that means closing down pubs and
bars and clubs then
that's absolutely what should happen and
do you think that is what should happen
now
definitely i think it should have
happened in september
the lockdown of springtime was a united
national
effort but what's happening now seems
more fractured
with local politicians out of step with
westminster
and even populations in cities like
manchester divided
over the best course of action and the
stakes seem higher
with businesses on the brink facing the
bleakest of winters
and those same cold months offering the
perfect conditions
for the virus to thrive the north will
rise out of this but will rise
in the united way and i think it's a
different version the north will come
out of this
and we keep thinking about the uh
thatcher and the pole taxing in glasgow
when they
inflicted that in glasgow first because
it's only scotland it doesn't matter
you know that kind of thinking and we're
thinking that here's oh they think it's
only the north
from an underground music scene
manchester has sprouted upwards on the
back of a now impressive hospitality
economy
but smart restaurants like 20 stories
that were exceeding expectations
are now shedding stuff we are kind of in
a danger zone with the rates at the
moment however there's no scientific
evidence that it's come from hospitality
versus universities versus education
versus workplaces
hospitality is a very very small portion
of that overall figure
yet we've been being punished for it
public health figures suggest the spread
of the virus is linked to food outlets
in around three percent of cases but
other data suggests it's higher
and shutting pubs in oldham had an
impact a lot of people are not listening
to the current
current restrictions with the pubs
closing at 10 p.m
while people still you know drinking
outside of the pubs
people still mixing in households so
maybe they should be stage three if you
consider
around the world i mean like in europe
in italy in spain
there was literal curfew there and still
even
i mean the government was doing quite a
lot of restrictions over there here in
the uk
with the grace of god i mean they are
quite reliant i mean they haven't put a
curfew in place for one minute
but this city heart of the northern
powerhouse
fears its heart will stop beating
without the laughter
the drinking and the music jason farrell
sky news